Today, we're going to continue our conversation
about monopoly and corporate power with David
Day in Who's the executive editor at The American
Prospect and also author of the new book Monopolize
Life in the Age of Corporate Power. It's great
to have you on, David.
Yeah, great to be here. Thanks.
So we recently spoke to Tom Hartman a little
bit, who's also written about Monopoly, and
he looked very, very closely at some of the
history of monopoly power in the United States.
Maybe we could start with you with a sort
of where we are today. What are the industries
in areas where monopoly power seems to be
sort of the prevailing force industries or
or other areas of American life?
I think it would be easier to tell you what
industries aren't OK, because it's it's a
very pervasive situation. Basically, look
across the landscape of America and all of
these sectors of the economy and you find
more concentration and more consolidation.
And that stands to reason because 40 years
ago, we kind of stopped enforcing antitrust
law and anti monopoly law. And this is the
result. So you have four banks that control
about 60 percent of all deposits for airlines
that control 80 percent of domestic routes.
You have concentration in hospital networks
where locally in metropolitan areas, about
90 percent of those are highly concentrated.
You have obviously pharmaceutical monopolies,
the monopolies granted by the government.
You have Facebook and Google and Amazon, all
predominant in their various parts of the
Internet search and social media and e-commerce.
So it's hard really to find an area that isn't
tightly concentrated at this stage.
Is there a fixed sort of sort of number that
you look at in terms of X number of firms
can can control Y percent of the market, or
does it really depend on the industry we're
talking about?
I mean, technically speaking, there is there's
this thing called the HERF and Hirschmann
index, which you don't have to know about
anymore, but it basically means it sets a
number above which a certain level, you know,
a market is highly concentrated. How you define
a market sometimes comes into play with these.
And at the at the at the level of enforcement,
sometimes that that line is drawn very tightly
to say, well, if you're talking about local
search in this local area, then maybe that's
not tightly concentrated. But if you look
sort of with your eyes in reality. And yes,
obviously a market is concentrated. You know,
there used to be much more precise standards
around this. That there were market share
thresholds where if the Justice Department
saw that a company owned more or controlled
more than 30 percent of a market or 35 or
some number, that they would step in and move
to break up that that that industry or or
deny a merger for those reasons. We don't
have that as much today of this. Hurford del
Hirschmann is very technical. As I say, you
can draw a line in various different ways.
And so, you know, I prefer to look at this
sort of in on an experimental basis. If you
go out in the world and you know, you go into
your supermarket aisle and you see the same,
it looks like a lot of different choices.
But a lot of them are made by the same companies,
you know, try to rent a car, go on a flight,
or do the things that you do throughout your
day. You find that there's more and more concentration
within those sectors and those service providers.
I think a lot of people, if fast. What's the
concern about monopoly power? Overwhelmingly,
people would say, well, a few firms control
a market. They can drive up the price that
I pay for a good or a service. But it goes
well beyond that, doesn't it?
Yes, it does. I mean, it doesn't go beyond
that in terms of how the Justice Department
and the Federal Trade Commission look at things
that they have now, this sort of consumer
welfare standards, and that has really been
devolved into price where if prices are expected
to go down, they approved the merger. But
there's so much more that goes into it. You're
talking about quality. You know, there's no
incentive to to make a service better. If
there's only one option that a person has
when you're talking about disruption of supply
chains and disruption of service, that magnifies
when there are only a few providers. You look
at airlines that glitch often their computer
systems and they shut down thousands of flights
and a cascading fashion. That wouldn't be
as much of a problem if there were many service
providers, many airline carriers that were
doing flights all around the nation.
You look at inequality and particularly regional
inequality. If the large firms on the coasts
are sort of extracting all the wealth from
areas that are said to be left behind, then
that creates a regional imbalance which has
implications not just for the economy, but
for our politics. If you think about innovation.
If you have large firms that don't want competitors,
they essentially sit on innovation, find innovators
and either copy their their efforts or or
squash their efforts or just buy them out
and then put them away. In the book, I talk
about a number of these possibilities and
circumstances where price is not the main
driver of what the harm is from Monopoly.
And so I think there's a tremendous amount
of implications to a more concentrated system.
I want to try to draw a little bit of a distinction
maybe between some industries and others and
kind of see where you come out on this in
thinking about airlines, for example. Airlines
are a little different than some other industries
in that the capital required because you're
talking about outrageously expensive airplanes.
Is the capital required is much higher than
in certain other industries, like, for example,
to open a local bookstore, which might eventually
be driven out of business by Amazon. Can you
talk a little bit about what type of changes
or solutions you would like to see within
the airline industry? Because it seems very
tough to do anything other than break up airlines
once they get too big because the barriers
to entry to begin. They're just so high.
I mean, what you're talking about there.
And you see this in utilities, for example.
So it doesn't cost. It's not cost effective
to run seven different wires to a particular
residence and have that person pick and choose
between the best service. Right. That just
would be completely cost prohibitive. So what
do we do with utilities? We heavily regulate
them so that they have a natural monopoly.
But we we put them in a situation where they're
not gouging customers, where they're not providing
substandard service and things like that.
And so you can sort of extend that out, the
regulated public utility model. And it actually
historically is how we handle the airlines
in the nineteen. We had a regulating board
called the Civil Aeronautics Board that said,
OK, you can you can have a certain amount
of profit for a certain level of capacity
on your airline, but you also have to serve
the entire country. You have to make sure
that if you live in Topeka, Kansas, or if
you live in Portland, Maine, you have access
to airlines and and flights and travel that
allows us to connect the entire country together.
What we did in the 1970s, we deregulated the
airlines. This led at first to an explosion
of competition, actually. But then at all,
it was it was it was not a virtuous competition.
Everyone was lowering and lowering prices
and then they completely cost effective. And
then you had this these giant amount of mergers.
And now what we have with the hub and scope
spoke model is that certain cities have been
just completely left behind. There just is
no airline service to large sections of the
country and certainly not direct flights.
And as cities like Cincinnati and others have
had seen there, there are international airports
sort of wither and then seen businesses who
who rely on business travel, leave those areas
and move to larger parts of the country. So
this is the sort of with a flick of a wrist
and the change of a where a hub is you can
turn a city from a world class city into a
second class city. And what the Civil Aeronautics
Board did was it was trying to prevent that.
It was trying to sort of level the playing
field. And so what I think needs to be done
is that when you have businesses like airlines
or utilities, you regulate them in such a
way that provides the most service to the
most people with with the least disruption.
And so airlines is actually a very good model
for this concept of a regulated public utility.
Can you talk a little bit about which industry
monopolies have been exposed through Corona
virus specifically? Are there are there certain
specific areas we should be looking where
the the virus and the pandemic have sort of
shined a light on, hey, this industry, that
industry is very much under monopoly control?
Well, I think what's happened is it's accelerated
trends that we've seen for the last 40 years
for a combination of factors. Number one,
it's simply the case that small businesses
do not have the kind of cash reserve that
large businesses do. We've seen thousands,
tens of thousands of small businesses go under,
thereby giving more market share to the large
incumbents. The second reason is the Keres
Act, which provided massive amounts of support
for large businesses, particularly those where
public publicly traded companies by propping
up asset prices, whereas small businesses
got this peepee, which is an eight week fund
for funding payrolls. Obviously, we're in
the six months month of this pandemic. So
eight weeks was definitely not enough. And
this imbalance has led to more and more market
share going towards the top. And then the
third thing is the changes in sort of our
our patterns of life, working from home, doing
deliveries that has benefited the large incumbents
like Amazon, like certainly the technological
things like Skype, what we're using now, which
is a division of Microsoft or Google tools
or or things that people are using to make
the work from home process work. So, you know,
I think I think what I would say is it's accelerated
this trend. And now we're at a position where
five major tech stocks are roughly one quarter
of the. Well, you of the entire S&P 500, which
has never been seen before in history. So
we're we're getting into this position with
fewer and fewer companies controlling more
and more of the economy.
And it's very dangerous for all the reasons
that we've outlined in the sort of limited
time we have left. What do you think is responsible
for getting the US away from breaking up monopolies?
And and actually, it's not even about creating
law, really just enforcing the laws that that
are there and were enforced more strictly
for a time. Is it as simple as regular regulatory
capture and the connections between the political
system and these corporations? Or is it more
more complex than that?
You can really boil it down to one man. And
that man is named Robert Bork. And he was
the former Reagan nominee for the Supreme
Court. He was a failed nominee for the Supreme
Court. He had much more impact outside of
the federal bench. He wrote the book, The
Antitrust Paradox in 1978, which sort of brought
us this consumer welfare prism through which
to view mergers. His idea was, as long as
a merger makes the merged company more efficient,
then we should allow the merger. And his corollary
was that any merger makes a company more efficient.
So it is perfectly tautological reasoning
at that. That essentially made it impossible
to stop a merger, and it was internalized
by both the antitrust authorities. The Justice
Department changed its guidelines in 1982
based on working principles and also the federal
judiciary, which internalized these concepts
as well. So thanks to Bork and the ideas that
he brought forward with the law and economics
music movement, which was largely out of the
university, Chicago, we we have changed and
reinterpreted all of these century old antitrust
laws without really changing a word. What
is what is changing now is we're starting
to get an awareness of that. And there's sort
of a nascent movement of thinkers and journalists
and academics who are pushing back. Finally
on on this sort of Balkhi and concept of antitrust.
And we're starting to see this bubble up into
the political system. You know, in July, we
had the House antitrust subcommittee, had
the CEOs of all the major tech companies in
for a hearing which was very aggressive as
to their anti-competitive harms that they
were placing on businesses and partners that
work with them as well as the public. So I
think the way that we're going to counteract
this is through a political movement. That's
really the only way that the antitrust laws
got put in place in the first place. And it's
the only way that we're going to get a a re
reinterpretation of them, if you will, to
to restore the concepts that were brought
forward initially with these laws, which was
to preserve, protect and preserve competition.
Well, well said. We've been speaking with
David De and who is the executive director
at the American Prospect.
The book is Monopolized Life in the Age of
Corporate Power.
David, really appreciate your time.
Well, thanks. Thanks for having me. Thanks
for your interest. The David Pakman Show David
Pakman dadgum.